you
all right we have officially a stacked
tournament eighty-five players just look
at the top list and you're going to get
a feel for how difficult is going to be
sometimes you are the hammer and
sometimes you're the nail let's see I'm
going to revisit this I'm going to play
a quick Queen b6 and my Queens gonna get
chased around the positional nests okay
I've had some experience with this
they're going with the minority attack
I'm playing on this wing 95 all right
um-hmm see how they recaptured do I not
win upon here okay they win that pond
okay I have a connected guy I'm going to
push here yes they are they're going to
win some material hmm Bishop takes pawn
queen here maybe target this guy okay I
got to get that pawn as soon as possible
not going to be easy
rook here the other rook rook on c2 be
okay take the pawn if they take on a
should still be good for maybe well
let's see what they do to take the rook
if the bishop takes okay they're going
to trade down not a good a not a good
defender here after blockade this is
going to hurt this is really going to
hurt their bishops going to kill my rook
yep incoming their bishops gonna kill my
rook and I don't have any time
whew this is painful
oh okay well don't I get
some material back it doesn't matter I
don't have any time
yeah time burners aren't going to work
here no you have zero seconds Oh packed
a tournament ah where did my time go
that dropped my deep on I shouldn't
allow that to happen I was forgetting
after Bishop takes on f6 my deep on was
struck out okay I gotta get some quick
wins here if you're gonna lose one let
that be the one you lose and the only
one hopefully okay they're going with a
quick something I don't know move every
pawn just one square Queen here okay I
don't know what that's about
Knight of 6 I got there clean I am the
rook and let's just develop queenside
castle because my Rick will have an open
file to work with clean side Cal so get
the other book to eat get the other up
to e are not moving they're not moving
any of their pieces okay they're just
going crazy town they're toying with me
they're toying with me where are you
going King where are you going I should
have made it this guy like long ago
I need my H pawns help apparently I
don't have any time I'm just going to do
time burners this game isn't ending if I
checkmate if it hasn't already happened
by checkmate it's just not going to
happen haha convincing win convincing
win well done 22 minutes remain I'm in
69th place at a2 Sneaky Pete I gotta try
some sneaky tactics that's exactly what
I need to do sneaky tactics throw your H
fun you need to get some quick wins to
get back in this quick wins because this
is only a 25
determine it's not it's not one that I
created so these are only 25-minute ones
they go fast okay I want to maintain my
bishop on that diagonal and okay they're
stopping me from you're gonna say
they're stopping me from kingside
castling yeah you need a rook for that
they take sage for illuminate their
light square bishop and look for made on
the light squares that's the highly
sophisticated plan no take my bishop a
bishop to h3 all right where's the mate
oh I almost melts of Queen g5 not cool
not cool at all
my g4 mmm all right I'm floundering
though I'm floundering my knight needs
to disrupt the rook I'm fishing for
tricks that just aren't there HC o h2
they could take that pond I could also I
could have also taken here with the fork
there's a fork so I get my material back
okay I get the Queen time they're down
on time back to tournament oh my good is
for I'm at four
let's go Queen Knight do some damage
that's a free pawn I'm going to pin me
okay Bishop I should have maybe develop
my dark square Bishop first huh let's go
queenside castle target this guy not
sure what I'm doing with that move now
let's just open up the H file
let's take stuff have a queen trade not
quite already
just drop your rook
drop your rook queen takes G would have
been pretty good I think at least Wow
what is that queen up to oh boy this is
a dangerous position I'm in a tough spot
they could play rook out five
yikes move rook mother bishop check they
have to block I don't like that I am so
restricted here okay let's hang on to
that pawn he's important it's a check
push this pawn now I'm gonna sack this
back I got a watch out for back rank
mates first they're going to do similar
they're going to give the material back
as well only have 12 seconds okay I have
to be at I'm burning machine let's just
push this pawn actually I should be able
to get this King position they're
running out of moves let's go here I
don't want to put them in stalemate okay
don't pay me
they're down on time ugliness ugliness
hey I got eight I need to get to the
front page you need to get to the front
page man 17 change okay okay okay let's
go with E for Bishop here that was ugly
they were really moving fast they had my
queen I think with rook out five I would
I would have been really close to just
resigning you know that they never want
to do you never want to resign and I
think I would have had to resign that
would have been a backbreaker a
backbreaker rook to f5 in that game I
get the F file okay
let's kill this Knight if he tries to
jump in here shatter their structure
look for Bishop takes e hits with check
rook on a to defend okay maybe I could
function on the light squares Queen g6
95 looks good although I take here
looking for made on h7 King has to run
he didn't run that's a quick win back to
tournament who first page well done
sixteen sixteen thirteen twelve twelve
twelve a lot of twelve sixteen minutes
30 seconds I'm a dirty cheater is top ok
grasshopper
okay grasshopper let's see what you do
about the wild h pun the wild h pun is
coming to get you Queen g4 not now
though go hunting go after that pawn
enter with the Queen Queen h7 could have
maybe Preem of that
alright let's maybe smash this open need
more fuel actually I have a plan to get
my Queen trapped is that your plan
my queen needs to be rescued I think she
was they could have done like a
perpetual against my queen
Thanks okay I have that guy fortunately
fortunately it's just somehow working
somehow it's just working yeah she
doesn't know where she wants to be she's
way too short on squares let's open
stuff up let's take that guy it's a
check queen block I want to keep the
Queens on you won't hear that too often
94 a night takes G hit the Queen on the
Queen and we take the night have you
thrown in this check they're not moving
okay here no matter what I hear that's a
bad pre-move here no matter what they
don't have any time
god I packed to term in 21 21 19 18 18
16 14 minutes remain 14 and change here
we go okay first time playing this guy
I'm gonna push no okay let's let's try
this not going to win any quick games by
playing like this but maybe that's
that's not a good idea then huh you need
to win quicker games let's stop the
knife from entering in the center to
give him a boot take my knight
okay I got the bishop pair some let
their presence be felt no they're gone
but I could still look towards having
the better Bishop let's do that no
matter what all right there go the
better bishops okay now we're into the
technical phase where to go exactly
triple pawns palm treo
this.h pawn rolling I want to maintain
my king position let's take here rook
activity first
okay I have a wonderful set of all
isolated ponds beautiful beautiful and
how exactly do I get activated let's
pitch upon that's how you do it that's
how you do it
disrupting my king position first nice
and now kicking my king away that's good
- and you're getting my last pond you
could have okay I have to go with time
burning tactics not fun classic time
burner right there hmm
they're going to move their king up
let's not do that they're down a time
ugliness its ugliness twenty five twenty
five twenty to twenty twelve minutes and
change it's a nail-biter it's a
nail-biter
okay another first and these arenas
these arena tournaments you get a nice
mix a nice mix alright I'm going to
throw the h p-- on the night is not on
f3o we're going to sack why not let's
keep pushing
isn't it close to me that's right back
to tournament I needed that I got to go
for those caveman style tactics twenty
five twenty five twenty four twenty two
Mon streak see if we keep it going oh I
think we're gonna get paired up did he
not just finish
finn's yes white again three whites this
isn't fair
I'm not complaining we're going to get
the same line now in earlier Queen to b6
puts a halt to all my tactics okay I
could still go with this mm all right
going to play their night in there see
oh they're going to play Knight takes
pawn miss that and I was ready to just
lose my queen this is no good okay okay
I have to unfortunately go into this I
think at least okay I'm fighting I'm
fighting without oh boy this is big
trouble dropping a lot of material okay
yes I'm on the prevent prevent mode here
ready to lose my queen again I think
flight square hmm I'm not sure what
that's doing this is going to hurt
Knight takes here I take C 3 is strong
or that there's some knight discovery I
think they had something better
Oh Queen takes F 2 yikes
ok let's block the Queen Queen to b2 and
it's just going to get simplified I got
to keep the Queen's on the board I'm
hitting the rook just fishing fishing
for things that just aren't there and
down on time I get a sack got open stuff
up yeah that goes a piece and yeah
that's done whoo okay soldier on somehow
10 seconds okay time burners is all I
have and I'm down on time oh that was a
big loss too because he was top and I
was so close to the top so close to the
top but not enough okay let's try
damaging their structure and playing
against their LightSquared Bishop do not
allow a five play against their
LightSquared Bishop Knight in here
Knight to f4 is going to hurt me
h4 h5 actually check that let's try
Knight g5 maybe no I'll go with the H
file if they give me that okay now we're
going here and then Queen h5 even if
they do that move I want the H file on
f7 Queen takes e5 is there queenside
castle f4 maybe okay I get this it's not
leading to me maybe they give me the F
file if they take let's open this up I'm
dropping a piece okay this is no good
they have everything defended and the
Queen's are going to be off I got to
play for time again they might miss
Queen takes F they did and that's mate
oh my goodness I didn't realize that's
rate 34 33 26 I need to get another
quick win to get back on fire
less than eight umm fins is at thirty
four thirty okay let's get the night out
Bishop c5 that was such an ugly game
many ugly games okay they're going with
this huh the old give some material and
then go hunt it down soon thereafter
how many more bishop moves am I going to
make let's throw a check already Wow
okay I'm ready to get mated I am ready
to get mated down a piece how did I
manage that take with the Queen
alright guess we're gonna do this this
is no good
hmm Wow
I'm getting squashed
okay I gotta somehow break this gut this
uh up I got to get some room for my king
I'm down way too much material against a
very good player and I feel like I
should resign I should ouch
what was I doing with my bishop my
bishop was getting kicked around 38 38
30 27 26 oh this is not the guy you want
to see okay he sees everything Knight f6
yeah it gets to a point where he just
sees everything it feels everything okay
let's just go here I didn't even see
that they could take my dark square
bishop okay Knight takes is happening
way too fast man way too fast are you
too fast okay I don't even know what to
say
this guy's brutal brutal man as a mouse
lip all right I got to do this scary
it's very scary this guy
yikes
very very scary I can't allow them to
trade down too easily and there I go on
them to trade down man okay I need a
piece on the board mmm that's a freebie
and that's gonna be mate whoo why are
they not meeting me okay finally they
mean you're 42 38 35 27 26 less than
five I got to come back I have to try
for third but third is even a
stretch nine minutes back there are nine
points back again and this is for whites
in a row mmm all right let's try an
exchange Slav let's see if we could get
we could sneak one win in here huh
all righty stay focused stay focused
let's get in a three
let's Castle now expand a little baby
Knight to c5 Knight takes here I think
was working okay queen post up before
they break with d4 Knight in there let's
just go here hmm let's go here they take
I take out on the rook secure my knight
position mm-hmm tough to suggest
something to do here don't know what to
do
all right try and be dangerous with my
knight I should have played g4 okay I
have a tricky night I'm the bishop
Brooke enters all right they saw that as
too strong could take oh I'm in check I
shouldn't have moved there okay I think
they miscalculated still tricky got to
hook that pawn down you go here give a
check if they take the pawn don't drop
your rook whatever you do no that was
almost a terrible mouse slip almost a
terrible one
alright let's just clear this out don't
Mouse lip finally I get that they could
have pre moved a up they could have made
a pawn move there alright no repetition
alright down on time man finally
that's not fair though that's like for
whites I think something needs to be
switched in the algorithm that's maybe
two I don't know for whites in a row
that's all I had
against fins not fair not fair defense
start a form now fair if it's Bishop c5
Knight takes takes towards the center
okay let's not chop a piece last time I
have my bishop coming out here it did
not end well at all maybe I can make
some magic happen on h2 or here again
it's crashing through all right I get to
move the knight with a check or get the
exchange I just get the Queen
maybe they resign now the dark squares
don't play Bishop f4 otherwise I could
pre move Queen g3 they resigned back to
tournament 44 40 to 40 I'm at 30 less
than a minute I'm a dirty cheater is up
there forty four fins 42 deep feller who
I don't think I've played yet it's 40
yikes
and nobody is perfect either everybody
has a speed bump
it's last game here let's just focus
let's just focus here get the bishop out
get your pawn in the center Bishop to d3
all right yeah Bishop d3 whip 2 c1 I
like this bishop backing up move because
it gives me play on the H file and
there's some strategy with not castling
too early so now maybe this is a threat
they have to tend to before I Castle I
want to keep that I want to delay
capturing or castling makes them play on
the Queen side mm-hmm okay let's jump up
here support my night without for maybe
even g4 g5 now yes let's just crack it
open
lean f3 to h3 yeah this is good now it's
probably leading to mate he had just the
doubling on the H file she will not be
denied that she is getting there h 2h
for one of the two the night moves I
have bishop there also I'm pinning the
night so Knight h5 is not a defense
anymore
that's matin one and then two right then
they resigned all right who very tough
tournament these arenas all right
top was forty four forty two forty two
thirty two thirty two thirty one thirty
thirty is where I stood first and two
hundred players oh my goodness let's see
who the two hundred were um
page two three hang on one moment you
couldn't see it on page one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
now I'm going fast here but there's a
lot to get through
Wow that's a very nice turnout
a very strong field
awesome to the 200 of you that took part
in this good games all alright